good morning believe nation today's
message is have a dream over to you Zig
Ziglar awake TV go when you're asleep
ladies and gentlemen you need your
dreams I'm here to tell you that when
you're wide awake you also need your
dreams you must have your goals you'll
never make it as a wandering generality
you must become a meaningful specific if
you're going to work tomorrow because
that's what you did yesterday you're not
going to be as good tomorrow as you are
yesterday because now you're two days
older and no closer to the goal which
you do not have you can't make it as a
wandering generality I think a lot of
people have a dream I think most people
have a dream I think the biggest
challenges people don't believe in their
dreams enough and now instead of it
being a real dream that you're aspiring
towards is just a wish i wish i could be
that person i wish i could accomplish
this goal i wish i could be this i wish
it could be that but because you don't
actually believe in it it just stays a
wish it says a hope and then you're not
taking any action towards actually
achieving it and making that dream
happen belief is the cornerstone when
you actually believe in what you're
doing then things start to happen your
habits start to change the people around
you starts to change momentum starts to
build up but you need to have that
belief in your dream belief that you can
actually make it happen and this is
something that in the early parts of my
business I struggled with and I wanted
to be a certain level of success in
entrepreneurship I wanted my company to
do well it wasn't doing well and I
thought the story told myself was I'm 19
years old I'm some punk kid you know
wildwood guys three times my age all
these degrees listen to me and as long
as I believe that story then I wasn't
making money right make it three hundred
dollars a month I couldn't get by but
once I realized that all they care about
is value and I can provide them value
and I believe in the value that I can
buy them then I could make my bigger
dreams come true and and every major
breakthrough that I've made in my
business has been because I've shattered
a limiting belief and so I think we all
have dreams I think if I ask you what is
your dream you could share below its do
you actually believe that you can make
that happen I want to be the world's
best salsa dancer maybe that's your goal
but do you actually believe that you can
make that happen do you feel that in
your core that you could be the world's
best salsa dancer or you can have the
most popular YouTube channel whatever it
is whatever your dream is do you feel it
in your core that you are that person
already because when you do that's when
the action starts to have so the
question today today is what's holding
back your belief in yourself and your
dreams leave in the comments below I'm
going to join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of n specimen